so let's assume that the allegations
against Jonathan majors are all accurate
and they ultimately have to drop him as
Kane the Conqueror and say for example
they decide to just rework the future of
the MCU question of what he's asking is
what do they do now here's exactly what
they do so we know at the end of Ant-Man
and Walsh Quantum Mania that all the
different variants of King every single
one are have all gathered together as
part of the Council of Kings they're all
in one location so what do you do you
wipe them all out in one Fell Swoop you
destroy them all at one time and when
the questions asked who in the world did
this we end up finding out it was a
variance some alternate reality version
of Doctor Doom who is pissed off because
some variant of Kane destroyed all the
superheroes on his world and almost
killed him and in retaliation he
destroys every single King realizing he
said he can seize control of the
Multiverse itself and then the entirety
of Secret Wars becomes a Doctor Doom
story let me know what you guys think
down in the comments